so eu darvish is set to work and trying
to win his seventh
consecutive start
swing and a miss he strikes out wong to
start it the 2-2 from darvish to edmond
fastball strike three call that's out
number two
jack flaherty going for st louis and
this year four starts 2-0
1.93 era
the pitch a swing and a miss a 95 mile
an hour fastball away
a double then a walk
now mayas
and he struck him out 95 that ball
exploded up in the zone and the second
strikeout for flaherty and the struggles
continue for habibuya two walks in the
inning the bags are now loaded wilson
contreras at the plate
that is gonna get in there and it's
gonna score two
riot followed by rizzo and it's two to
nothing here in the first
a swing and a mass and on three pitches
flaherty strikes out maven
there's a better slider back to back
strikeout
the 2-2 to carpenter
strength recall carpenter caught looking
strikeout number three comes on a
breaking ball a little back door action
baez
flags it down
nine up nine down for darvish
there's a ground ball deep in the hole
de young to the stretching wong stayed
on the bag and they get the force goes a
long way makes a good throw colton turns
into in a play like that he essentially
turns into a first base and trust came
through with a
two out bases loaded two-run single in
the first
a swing and a base hit to right field
the cubs get another run hayward will
stop at second coming into score as baez
wilson contreras has driven in all three
runs
strike three called fastball second
straight time ron you just got done
saying
he was looking for something off speed
and a fastball struck him out in the
first they did the exact same thing has
just happened in the third 12 cardinals
have been up 12 have gone down in order
as udarvish has been perfect so far
tonight
bald strike three miller really upset
similar to the pitch he threw to get
carpenter looking back door breaking
ball over the outside corner
swing and a miss strike three
seven strikeouts now for darvish the 2-2
to molina swung on and missed
strike three
you darvish perfect through five well
this has been a pleasure to watch
darvish through five
and he lifts it in the air
right center maven back and it's gone
that breaks up the perfect game a home
run that carries out of here it's a home
run for carpenter
all he really does here is just get this
slider up in the air
and it goes you see him extend he
reaches a little bit quiet knows get on
the board
swinging in a missed strike three
o'neal chased a pitch that broke off the
outside corner that's eight strikeouts
for you darmish travis two for two and
has knocked in all three for the cubs
[Music]
that's deep left center
the only way he could pick up an rbi in
this at bat
is to drive in himself
harris has driven in all four runs
and this was a rocket a line drive to
the seats
in left center
his fifth of the year he's driven in
four
what a night for wilson contreras
darvish rolling along on a one hitter
and he strikes out this time
it's 10 for darvish
overpowered him with a fastball and that
hasn't happened often this year
miller strikes out
that's 11 strikeouts for darvish he has
been masterful
tonight
four to one it is a safe spot for jeremy
jeffress who's been one of the best
in the business here in 2020
strike three call jeffers came right
back with that split finger pitch and
again i think carlson was wise to it he
laid off of it but angel hernandez
thought it was good enough
there's a double play ball right behind
the bag tag two
game over
cubs win
that was fun